hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for
monday november 16 2020 what's going on
how
ah yeah um how's it going i'm watching
the end of the pats game as i recorded
this
recording this uh sunday night
to what does that say my old eyes here 2
25 to go in a range-soaked game
um what do we got i can't even see 23 to
pets trying to hang on for a hard-earned
victory all of these guys who rode off
the pants
so all the injuries and all the people
who said they weren't playing because of
covid
and all of this [ __ ] look at the ravens
talking [ __ ] i love it
look at him yelling at cam newton it's a
[ __ ] great game
um anyway i missed all the football baby
i missed all the football i worked my
[ __ ]
red balls off this weekend
[Laughter]
i did i had a [ __ ] 11 hour day on
saturday
and i've been writing uh the final
episode unfortunately of efforts for
family but you know what i'd rather
leave before people are sick of us
um but uh
so i've been writing that all freaking
day today
uh started a little bit friday a little
bit saturday i was busy saturday so i
had to
you know only did a couple of pages but
today i knocked out like a good 15 so
i'm hoping to polish it off tomorrow
and uh but meanwhile i missed all of the
football but i i did look at some of the
highlights
um of what was going on out there uh
i i taped this game thank god the bills
versus the cardinals
two two great teams to watch i've been
watching the bills almost every single
week
i do it i've tape i'm taping so many
[ __ ] games because i'm
at this covi and i'm home i watch like a
game possibly two
for the whole week i didn't tape too
many today kind of [ __ ]
up but i was busy but i usually you know
i'll take three or four you know if you
listen to this podcast this is getting
old but
i you know couple two three one o'clock
couple two three
um four o'clock games i'll watch a game
and then i watch the sunday night game
then i got monday night football
and then tuesday wednesday i watch a
couple games i got thursday night
football friday saturday watch a couple
of games speaking of games
i'll tell you what we'll turn 2020
around
for me is if the university of indiana
somehow figures out a way to beat ohio
state on saturday
all right well they already beat who'd
they beat this year they beat uh
penn state who's having a oh they're
having a rough one okay last i heard
they were like [ __ ] owen three
i know it's beyond that but um did they
beat michigan state they beat some big
goddamn people i think they beat
michigan too said do they be little [ __ ]
bill you got the internet right here
you got the old internet interweb why
don't you look it up
and find out who won and figure out
whether we landed on the moon or not
indiana who's your football
versity football
schedule all right let's see what we got
here
all right seymour what have they done
all year
okay yes they beat michigan they beat
penn state
they beat rutgers they beat eastern
illinois the way they should have 52 to
nothing
um and now they got ohio state
indiana is somehow indiana football
is ranked ninth when was the last time
indiana football was ranked that high
ohio state
number three which is actually kind of
low for them there always seem to be
number two and number one
or three or whatever that's about right
so i mean
it's a daunting task to try to go
in there and and uh beat ohio state well
there's really no home field advantage
even if it's in
in indiana it doesn't even matter
because there's like [ __ ] nobody
there
but um [ __ ] the pat's gotta punt it away
with how much time left minute ten
minute nine minute eight minute seven
don't touch it
six five oh that's plenty of time
plenty of time in today's nfl the guy
like lamar
jackson you guys might hear me watch my
pat's louvres live
hey here's a question i have for you
it's 2317.
if baltimore ties it up
do you go for one or do you go for two
i'm of course being facetious but i
swear to god that's
how i i saw so many goddamn games
in the past [ __ ] couple of weeks
where these guys they
did they're going for a [ __ ] they're
going for two-point conversions in like
the second quarter now it's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
alamar run run first down getting out of
bounds
jesus christ 56 seconds to go
um you know what's gonna happen this is
all these [ __ ] games it's it goes
right down to the 20 yard line then you
gotta [ __ ] sit here and die a
thousand deaths as they get four shots
at the end zone please holding holding
oh
[ __ ] you
oh the dreaded holding call the only
time they show an offensive lineman's
face he probably did a great job all
night poor bastard look at him
squeezing that fat head and that [ __ ]
helmet
um he looks like me riding a bicycle um
my face gets all [ __ ] red let's see
what he did here
oh you guys he hooked him i don't know
look pretty standard
you know you could call holding on every
play um
anyway i was watching this game and i
actually texted somebody about this
about this did i already talk about this
when i was watching the kansas city
chiefs last week
who the [ __ ] were they playing i already
forget who the [ __ ] they were playing
um let me see here i'll find it here
i'll find it here for you but anyway
the team beating them had no business
beating them
right they had no [ __ ] those the
panthers
so here's the text i sent them i sent
this guy who knows all about football i
said so the panthers scored a td
and kicked an extra point it makes it
26-24
chiefs down by two there's nine minutes
left in the game
and the panthers decide to try an onside
kick which has a six percent
success rate the chiefs
um they didn't recover but the ball
didn't go 10 yards
so now there's a penalty and the chief's
got the ball that on the panthers own
39-yard line like five six plays later
kc scores a touchdown they gave it right
back to him
so then the panthers with teddy
bridgewater who i love
go down the whole length of the field
score another touchdown
that makes it 33-31 did they just kick
the extra point
which if they did on the first one
they'd only be down one and now it'd be
a tie game
instead they on side again they double
down again
kc [ __ ] recovers at the panthers 42
they get the [ __ ] ball back again um
fortunately defense gets some four and
out but by the time the [ __ ]
panthers got the ball back there wasn't
enough time to drive down the length of
the field
and that first on-site kick was with
like nine minutes
left in the [ __ ] game it doesn't make
any sense this stupid [ __ ] with the
analytics what happened i'm over here
talking
there's two seconds left 12 seconds
that's all the way across the room two
seconds i think
two seconds left holy [ __ ] pat's looking
to get their fourth win of the year four
and five
starting to figure things out i love it
i love it jacoby myers becoming our
number one
lamar jackson walking off the field
um hey man i don't care what year it is
you beat the [ __ ] ravens that's a uh
that's a big victory
buffalo lost again today lost a
heartbreaker
against the cardinals huh and kyla
murray
who was telling you about kylo murray
two three weeks ago
i was now everybody's caught up with me
the whole world is 21 days behind me
i'm kidding everybody know um
you know what i love about that [ __ ]
full mask
that harbaugh's wearing you can't watch
him whine throughout the whole [ __ ]
game
he's another one of those guys who
[ __ ] was jumping on the path saying
that they were all these [ __ ] guys
play golf too
which is just a cheating man's game um
i don't know why i go off on golf
chargers lose again
but you know they got their quarterback
they do got their quarterback um who
actually can he get hurt or something
like that
was that last week and tyrod taylor came
in
um who by the way lost his starting job
because he hurt his ribs
and he was getting injected with the
painkiller and unfortunately
they punctured his lung and he went out
there and he's like i can't [ __ ]
breathe
and then they brought in this uh what's
this not justin herbert and he's had the
job ever since
crazy crazy crazy all right i think
that's about all i can talk considering
i didn't watch any of the goddamn games
although i did watch my patriots
i [ __ ] love the pets you know what's
so weird they feel like my team again
that whole time when they were winning
it felt like i was dreaming it
and now they're struggling you know
trying to get four and five trying to
get up to 500 i'm like this is the
[ __ ] team i
grew up with
um so anyway uh a couple of legends died
in the past week i gotta
give a shout out here to them um tommy
heintzen
the great great tommy heintzen 10-time
nba championship eight-time
winner eight times as a player two times
as a coach
74 and 76 i believe as a coach
he's part of those great bill russell
bob jacuzzi
you know red r backs that years that um
put to celtics and the nba on the map
really put the nba in the
nba on the map because they used to and
during the off season
they would travel around the country
selling the game the pro game to
all these different areas i read this
whole book on bob cousy and um
and bill russell and how uh you know
they go
down the south and like bob cousy could
walk in the front door and bill russell
couldn't it was [ __ ] nuts
um but anyway uh
i knew him as uh
the color commentator when you would
watch a celtic game and
you know they just don't make them like
that anymore
he just was there was just nothing
better you know he hated the officiating
every single game but when he really
hated it it was just so
[ __ ] entertaining and he was just
such a celtic
and he's such a homer it was so much fun
it's one of the things that i really
miss
about um
[Music]
sports broadcasting is it's just become
so goddamn corporate i just miss
the homer who just cannot see any fault
in his own team and you know as an
announcer
they just were fun as hell i used to
like you know
when the um and the whole sports package
thing
was first blowing up there was a few
homers left
there was that guy who used to call the
uh buffalo sabres games forgive me
sports fans because i don't know
everybody's name i love listening to
that guy
uh he was fun to listen to
um there was a guy that was doing the
raiders on the radio that was great to
listen to he wasn't necessarily a homer
but he just sounded like an old school
announcer
and um i don't know tommy heinstein was
in that class he should be in the hall
of fame if he isn't as a broadcaster
i absolutely love listening to call
games and so rest in peace to the great
tommy heinsohn
and uh paul horning
but which for my whole life i thought it
was spelled h-o-r-n-i-n-g
but it's actually spelled like
h-o-r-n-u-n-g
or something like that and um
i was watching a whole thing on him i'm
sort of fascinated
with uh
i don't know with with great players
that end up on these weird teams and you
just forget
you know like tony dorsett played a year
for the broncos
they had like 700 yards too um
paul horning and ended up on the saints
which who the hell remembers that i
think the one everybody remembers would
be like joe namath on the rams
or like johnny united us on san diego
but like some of them i always do this
with joe bartnick he always brings up
franco harris
on the seattle seahawks um
i'm trying to think of the other one
eric dickerson is like a falcon
um you know or like
verzi always talks hoop or he'll talk
about like patrick ewing
as a seattle sonic when he had those
really bad uniforms
there was a period in the nfl i'm sorry
in the nhl
in the nba particularly the nhl
where they just had some of the ugliest
[ __ ] uniforms i've ever seen
at least the ones from the 70s are funny
but um holy [ __ ] like the islanders oh
my god whatever the [ __ ] that mess was
the buffalo sabres they had shitty ones
[Music]
the um had shitty ones just horrific
i'm trying to think like the whole it's
like the whole league decided to just
pick the ugliest color combinations
and then they just changed legendary
jerseys and one of the smartest things
they did was they went back the
islanders got back to theirs the sabres
got back to theirs
canucks went back to their originals
before that [ __ ]
eye chart thing whatever the hell they
had
back um in like the 70s but
um anyway
anyway my daughter said the funniest
goddamn thing the other day
you know i'm measuring her she's growing
like you can't believe like i had to
raise the handlebars on her
tricycle twice and it's like official i
gotta get her
like uh santa has to go get her a bike
at some point right
and um so i've been measuring her i got
inside the closet you know you make the
little marks and stuff
so she she sees me draw on the wall
which is not a good thing right so now
she wants to do it
so the next day she scribbles all over
the wall go no you can't do that you
can't do that right
so she's so smart she knows she can't
draw on the wall but she wants to
because i did
so what does she do she tells me she
wants to measure me she doesn't want to
measure me she just wants to draw on the
wall and uh so i go okay
well but you can't draw on the wall but
she goes but dada i want to i want to
draw on the wall i go just use the
eraser
you can't draw on the wall you got to
pretend just you can't draw on the wall
and she goes well i don't know what to
tell you
like where the hell did you get that
you know i've been doing some stand-up
spots around town
trying to get ready for this tour of
texas you know these [ __ ] people out
there would wear masks so this tour
doesn't get canceled
and i said to her uh you know i've been
telling her like
she's like daddy wait you got to work
tonight and i was like yeah she's like i
don't want you ever to work again which
made me feel great right
it's like i can't i got to go out and go
tell jokes so then she says to me
she goes she goes what is telling
jokes exactly and that's like her new
thing now everything is exactly
i have to cook this dinner what is
cooking exactly
so i've been having fun with her and my
son is just
the cutest little kid
ever ever and uh obviously at my age
this is our last one so i'm really
trying to enjoy
having a little baby and he's getting
ready to start crawling he's strong as
hell
um and he's just so freaking happy
all the time smiles all the time the
biggest damn smile it's the greatest
thing
it's the greatest thing as much as this
year has sucked and has been hard on so
many people the one thing that is cool
is being a stand-up comedian and your
kid's almost six months old
and you've seen him every single day of
of the kid's life is pretty freaking
awesome
um and quality time too so um
thankful for all of that how about the
pats jc
jackson right
like some unsigned guy comes in filling
in a roll and all of a sudden he's
leading the league in interceptions got
like six or seven of them oh drew brees
got hurt
so jameis winston came in how about that
alvin kamara kid
amazing all right now let's talk let's
talk a little bit of sports here
um oh and it's another game i watched i
watched so many [ __ ] football games
this week i watched that thursday night
game
who's that [ __ ] guy in the colts that
hines kid
jesus christ that reminded me because he
played for the colts there's a famous
monday night football
game that only old people like me
remember joe
washington in the rain went off on the
new england patriots he had like six
touchdowns
it's like he returned like a kickoff or
a punt for a touchdown
he he ran for touchdowns he he caught
touchdowns
he was just like it was like watching a
movie
um there's there was a couple famous
monday night football games when i was a
kid there was joe washington's game when
he played for the colts
um against the patriots there was
another patriot i think was against the
patriots that run
i don't know if it was monday night
football o.j simpson had where he's
running in the rain
fell down slid on his ass got back up
and kept running
um
i guess they were these are all patriots
highlights because i remember steve
grogan's 50-yard naked bootleg
was a great one and i would say
uh these are like 70s possibly 1980 with
the uh
the earl campbell when they ran the ball
to the right
and he just turned the corner and
everybody thought they had the angle on
this big
guy and they didn't and he was just gone
um but my favorite monday night football
game of all time
has got to be uh 1985
when dan marino
beat the undefeated chicago bears on
monday night football
it was unbelievable like he beat the 46
defense
something nobody could do that year he
went out and did it
and then they played the patriots in the
orange bowl and we hadn't won there in
like 20 years
in the afc championship game and all
they had to do was get by the [ __ ]
sad sack pats who could never make it
happen
back then and there would be the rematch
and the bears could
avenge their one loss i mean it would i
mean
the hype for that [ __ ] game would
have been so goddamn crazy but
football gods didn't want it to happen
and the patriots ended up winning the
game
and then we went to the super bowl and
got absolutely
[ __ ] smoked for the record we were up
three to nothing when tony franklin
kicked a field goal and then that was
just [ __ ] it
oh and as sad as it was to watch my pats
get
[ __ ] smoked the worst thing was the
bears forgot to give walter payton a
touchdown they gave it to [ __ ]
william the refrigerator prairie anyway
um
i got to tell you i read up on that guy
and i guess he's in a bad way
with his health and um
i you know people are trying to help him
but he's like nah man
this is how i want to go out and he's
just hanging out
and he's wherever he's at or something
or reading this thing he was just you
know
having some drinks and enjoying his life
there there really is something to be
said
about that like um
i don't know if you just decide i mean
it's got to be hard for the people
around you that love you but if you just
decide like look man
i ain't you know i i'm just look
if i want to eat it i'm eating it if i
want to drink it i'm drinking it i'm
just going to [ __ ]
have a good time you know
you know in a weird way that's actually
better for the earth
you know if people just in general on
average
kind of knocked off late 50s early 60s
like it seemed like they did when i was
growing up
like people just dropped in their 60s if
you got to your 70s it was
it seemed anyway like it was [ __ ]
amazing um
it just seemed like everybody like it 67
64.
you know when they couldn't look you
know machines look in your heart to be
like dude you gotta lay off this [ __ ] or
whatever the hell it is you're doing
people just [ __ ] dropped
am i dumb ass i'm always watching like
old [ __ ] uh
movies and stuff and um
i uh i always go on imdb and i try to
see who's still alive you know who's
dead or whatever and i [ __ ]
um yeah that's what i found the amount
of the amount of people that just
[ __ ] dropped
dropped what movie did i see the other
night i was looking up the cast
and they were just [ __ ] gone
like 47 53
61 really you know for nowadays like
young numbers but um
i don't know in the overall grand scheme
of things
you know the kids who got to inherit the
world it's a good thing you know so
i don't know what am i what am i talking
about i guess it's all right to [ __ ]
uh
go out there and go party have a good
time
and get the [ __ ] out of the way you know
maybe we maybe we go back to that maybe
we go back to like having the [ __ ]
bottle of scotch in the bottom of your
desk
somebody's having a rough day at sales
and you
bring them in you give them a brow
beating and then you give them a shot of
[ __ ]
you know whiskey all right get back out
there try to sell some [ __ ]
um i didn't get to watch the moto gp
race today but obviously i saw that uh
uh how do you say joanne joanne
mir won his first moto gp championship
suzuki's first
uh motogp championship i think they said
in 23 years
um it was just uh
an amazing amazing sport uh lewis
hamilton
uh wrapped up the championship his
seventh f1 championship
that has to be a record you can't tell
me somebody's wanted more than that
i feel bad i kind of gave up on f1 i
haven't watched it in a while
i just got bored lewis hamilton is just
so much better than everybody else
mercedes is so much better than
everybody else
and i was kind of hoping like for a
little ferrari it was good there for a
minute where ferrari
red bull were sort of challenging them
and now it's just sort of
all right is botox going to win hamilton
going to let botos win this one i don't
[ __ ] know
um but anyways why did i write adam and
eve
that has to be a typo oh [ __ ] i think
that that's the advertising and that got
oh yeah that's what happened it's like
what the [ __ ] am i writing i'm writing
religious [ __ ] here
adam i need we need to move this down
the list here ah jeez bill
what are you doing anybody see bill mars
going off on [ __ ] what's wrong with
the democratic party
jesus christ that guy was
[ __ ] hitting nothing but dingers i
can't tell you the amount of people that
i've talked to that
basically said that have not said it as
eloquently
that whole [ __ ]
psycho [ __ ] left has hurt the
democratic party so much
with their canceling of people and and
policing people on words and [ __ ]
trying to just
end people just trying to end people i
never
in a million [ __ ] years ever thought
that the [ __ ] left would be involved
in that
it's funny to watch the right criticize
it where it's just like now now
now now easy now
you guys [ __ ] canceling the dixie
chicks and anybody in
[ __ ] country music who doesn't say
exactly what the [ __ ] you want
come on all the way back to the [ __ ]
red scare you [ __ ] lunatics have been
doing that forever
okay you always went too hard but then i
always thought the liberals went a
little too light like oh hey man like
you know
if that guy was like in a better
neighborhood maybe he'd be like a doctor
man
well maybe he'd still be a piece of [ __ ]
like they go too far the other way so i
mean this you got to have like some sort
of
i don't know if i'm probably not making
any sense i'm not the person to do this
[ __ ] but whatever watch that bill maher
rant man it was uh
it's it's it's [ __ ] amazing um
i don't know it just makes sense to me
and i just don't understand this whole
thing that
you know you are defined
like by one tweet eight years ago or
one event that is who the [ __ ] you are
um if you really buy into that [ __ ] like
you're
you're not being honest with yourself i
think
because i human beings
are extremely complex and they are
capable
of anything at any moment
you know some people swing a little
[ __ ] wider
you know i'm obviously not talking about
illegal [ __ ] i'm just saying about
saying stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] up making
mistakes
um this whole [ __ ] world where you're
just gonna be like
basically unforgiving um
especially if it's a guy because it's
also there's an incredible level of
sexism involved in it
where it all just sort of got tied into
this whole
like woman's movement and blah blah blah
so then it was kind of like
all of a sudden as a man you were like
you know there was already nine guilty
votes casted against you before you even
accused of something um
well it's just it's just it's
ignorant all right to just sit there and
try and suggest that only
one race of people one sex of people
one uh sexual orientation of people are
inherently evil and everybody else is a
[ __ ] saint
is uh it's a little bizarre but you know
who the [ __ ] am i to tell you not to do
it it's weird
um anyway plowing ahead here plowing
ahead plowing ahead uh all right well
let's
let's get to some of the advertising i
already did a little bit of a uh
a little sort of pre-read here adam and
eve everybody it's adam and eve
god made adam and eve two white people
to start the whole thing and somehow we
got a bunch of different races out of it
it doesn't make sense if you think about
it
um all right adam and eve monday morning
podcast is brought to you by
adam edie adam and eve uh adam and eve
says the best part of staying at home is
playing at home
sex toys make being at home way more
enjoyable
do you think like eve nagged adam
and how much [ __ ] do you think he took
he's like yeah you are gonna do better
than me i'm the only guy in the [ __ ]
we're in paradise and you're still
bitching
yeah go [ __ ] yourself what are you gonna
do okay i'm gonna go [ __ ] a horse
um you'll be back eve
don't leave me uh sex toys make being at
home way
more enjoyable hell even shopping from
home is
more enjoyable when you're shopping for
sex toys
and adam and eve has thousands of
products
who would have thought there's a
thousand different well i guess there's
a thousand different things people are
into
so there's something for everyone free
stuff is awesome but free stuff to spice
up your bedroom
is even better take advantage of the
downtime
and choose almost any one item at 50
percent off
when you do you'll also get 10 free
boredom busting gifts including six
spicy movies a three-piece bonus kit
and best of all free shipping delivered
discreetly right to your door
just remember to use the code burr
b-u-r-r at checkout
go to adamandeve.com and use that offer
code burr one more time that's adam and
eve
dot com e-v-e for all you brainiacs out
there adam is a-d-a-a-m
all right i'd spell it a-d-e-m adam
and eve e-e-v-e
adam and eve a-d-a-m and eve eve.com
offer code burr all right i'm sorry that
i brought all you guys down to my level
of stupidity there
i'm sure you guys know how to especially
you guys there go to church every week
uh my my bookie hey how the [ __ ] you
doing
uh late fall college ball the nba bubble
and use
ufc fight island it's clear 2020 has
been a year unlike any other
which is why you need a sports book
which offers
with offers unlike any other get some
skin in the game
with my bookie where odds boosts
lightning deals and free bets await
all season long and with turkey day
right around the corner
there really is no better time to feast
on some nfl action
whether you're a first-time customer or
have been playing with my bookie for
years
there is no shortage on value
of value be found in thousands of games
unique prop bets and contests that they
offer
every week sign up or get reloaded find
an edge
make your bet and get paid they also
boost a fully fledged casino platform
giving you access to all the classic
table slot and card games you'd expect
to find at your local spot
and the best part is at my bookie the
doors never close so you can continue to
build your bankroll even after the
stadium lights have gone out
make the night make the right play and
sign up today at my bookie
and when you do use promo codeburr burr
to get your deposit matched halfway all
the way up to a thousand bucks
the terms are simple you put in 200
bucks they'll match you
with another 100 in your account
if you're already planning to bet this
season this is free betting money
it's winning season at my bookies so
come join in on all the fun and win some
cash while you're at it
all right oh look who's here everybody
who
do me undies me undies it started with
adam and eve
me undies beyond these along came a guy
named steve
they had a two on one and god got mad
they said it was fruit
but that wasn't true she had a [ __ ]
threesome and god said she was a [ __ ]
because the book was right written by a
bunch of guys
who were [ __ ] sexist i guess they
weren't sexist it was back in the day
go easy at my bookie you shouldn't bet
all night just bet with money you can
afford to lose
all right me undies these are great to
have after you've been on my booking and
you're [ __ ] yourself with two
minutes left
move aside bears this is the humans time
to hibernate the holiday season
dooby dooby do um we actu this holiday
season we actually have an excuse to go
not to go to aunt carol's house and my
undies is stoked to say their cozy
loungewear and comfy undies will be your
holiday hibernation uniform
this is your sign stay in order in
cuddle up be a bear
in lounge pants and hibernate your
little butt off
gifting me undies to friends slash
family and yourself
this holiday season you're encouraging
uh we're encouraging you
to take it eat take it easy take it easy
soften the stress
literally no more malls and wild holiday
shopping order me
undies online uh they offer free
shipping
gift your family and friends with the
cozieth cloth
clothes sorry and undies for some
well-dressed
me time uh heck give yourself some
some of the coziest clothes and undies
for some well-deserved
me time this year we're staying in and
we're going to be damn company while we
do you kidding me
you go to adam and eve and get some sex
toys you do a little gambling at my
bookie and you do it all in your [ __ ]
loungewear
i'm setting you up uh the undies have
brand
spanking new winter products this year
get your cozy on
with their new pj sets and holiday theme
prints keep an eye out
for other new additions meundies also
has the greatest membership program
on the face of the earth earth earth get
a new pair of undies or socks every
month
and give your top drawer a complete
refresh me undies has a great offer for
my listeners any first-time purchasers
you get 15
off and free shipping myani's also has
their problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it
no caveats no questions to get your 15
off your first order
and free shipping go to meundies.com
that's me undies.com
m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
all right we got one more here butcher
box
oh man i just got a whole delivery of
their stuff
um i am ready i am ready
for the next [ __ ] shutdown whatever
they call it lockdown
you know these [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
want to wear masks just don't want to
wear uh
butcher box not everyone has convenient
access to high quality meat
luckily today's sponsor butcher box
believes everyone deserves high quality
humanely sourced meat
butcher box couldn't be easier just sign
up select your box and they ship it
right to your door every month
and when you sign up now you get their
steak sampler with six
grass-fed grass-finished steaks because
the best steak night
is a free steak night every month
butcher box ships curated selections of
high quality meat right to your home
no added antibiotics or hormones ever
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
and enough for 24 individual meals yeah
i just got some of that chicken you can
tell it's like
all natural because of the size of it
it's not that roided up
schwarzenegger chicken breast that you
get down at the local grocery store
it's the size it's supposed to be you
know
and it's good for you and you eat it you
and you get in shape as opposed to
[ __ ] eating that stuff and all of a
sudden you're you're attracted to a
horse because god knows what they're
giving i don't let's stay with the cop
here
packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
i can customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way i get exactly what i
want it's the best meat shipped right to
my door which means one less trip to the
grocers
uh my favorite uh i like that i like the
heritage bread
heritage breed pork that's my favorite
thing um
bread pork however you say it uh i love
it it's absolutely delicious
and i can never finish it and then what
i do the next day is i make my own
sort of white boy uh whatever
tacos with it i have a great [ __ ]
time um
and it's delicious my wife comes over
like oh what are you doing over here i'm
like i'm making myself some tacos
all right options like 100 grass-fed
beef uh
grass-fed and finish beef free-range
organic chicken heritage pork my
favorite wild caught alaskan salmon you
don't know what they're gonna
do and sugar slash nitrate free bacon
butcher box is the most affordable
and convenient way to get healthy
humanely raised meat uh before they kill
it
with butcher box you get the highest
quality meat around for just six dollars
a meal
and they even have free shipping
nationwide except alaska and hawaii
but if you live in alaska you should be
trapping your own goddamn meat in hawaii
what are you doing out there huh
what are you doing you got you got all
that [ __ ] what do you gotta pineapple
and [ __ ] all that great [ __ ] you know
i'm surfing
i don't know why am i saying that they
probably want to ship meat there too who
knows you might maybe want to pretend
you're on the mainland
get a [ __ ] cow sent out to you uh for
a limited time
new members get six free grass-fed
grass-finished steaks when they go to
butcherbox.com
that's two new york strips and four top
sirloins
add it to your first box for free act
quickly this offer is only good
through cyber monday whatever the [ __ ]
that is that's six grass-free
grass-fed grass-finished steaks for free
in your first box just go to
butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com bur
all right so here we are so over the
last couple of weeks
over the last couple of weeks oh [ __ ] is
my thing gonna die here my recorder
might die
um it's acting weird i just charged it
anyways uh
what do i got here oh i've been talking
to um believe it or not i don't know how
i've been talking to
architect students in egypt
and i opened a whole new world for
myself here
look at this [ __ ] i'm getting people
writing in this guy love from iran
um hey bill i'm a postgraduate student
from iran
congratulations once you graduated been
listening to your podcast for the past
few months
and i've been a huge fan of yours since
you played that role in breaking bad
uh you are hilarious keep it up with the
good work and please convince your
government not to invade us we're
miserable enough as it is with our
shitty economy
much love from tehran and go [ __ ]
yourself
um i hope we don't because
you know there's people like you there
who's just a post-graduate trying to get
a [ __ ] job
it's it's absolutely ridiculous with how
much we know
and how much technology we have that we
still solve problems by going to war
it's so
i can't how is it legal
you know you can't just go down the
street and kill somebody
but if you're you go to war then it's
it's fine
none of it none of it makes sense i
don't know um the only way i can make a
rational
like get my head around it is i really
just think that psychos
like want to run a country
okay i think you you like as they always
say you they're they're a little [ __ ]
nuts there's something [ __ ] wrong
with them
um or maybe i'm just a [ __ ] and i can't
see the world for what it is in this i
don't know
i don't i don't know who knows but
whatever yeah i really hope we don't do
that
we're already [ __ ] bankrupt i just
think we should just
you know i think we have plenty of
natural resources here
okay we should just [ __ ] embrace the
sun and use it
and just [ __ ] stop [ __ ] with
everybody and then no one no one wants
to
hurt us anymore am i oversimplifying
this of course i am stand up comedian
all right big fan from bahrain
hey there billy blue balls this is a
follow-up on the two fans who reached
out to you from egypt i am crushing the
middle east right now
i am a 24 year old guy from bahrain and
i've been a fan of yours for over seven
years
how the [ __ ] do you know who i am that's
unbelievable
i'm about to graduate from college with
a degree in english literature
and your podcast has made my journey a
lot easier
oh god i'm sure you know every english
curse word listen to this thing
the two architects from egypt said that
they listen to you while
studying i couldn't do that because
reading the incoherent
ramblings of shakespeare and fitzgerald
wouldn't let me focus on your poetic
language
i hate that [ __ ] i hate shakespeare i
respect shakespeare but i [ __ ] hate
it cause i don't know what they're
talking about
and it makes me feel dumb so it has
nothing to do with my fellow william
here
i just it's just you know i can't even
read the [ __ ] constitution
um all the best to you forget about the
bible
this isn't the way people talk now
that's how dumb i am
all the best to you and your beautiful
family may you maybe you can visit
bahrain once
to watch an f1 race i would love to do
that
listen okay this is what i need you guys
to do over there
i need you to give me the over under
of me going over there and not getting
kidnapped because of some [ __ ] that some
oil companies from my country did
i'm going over there a [ __ ] white
dude
right blue chip [ __ ]
hostage all right i know we didn't do
something
you gotta you gotta like uh
you know what i mean you know you guys
all look at america and you just think
it's a bunch of people going yeah
shooting a [ __ ] gun in the air eating
a [ __ ] pie riding on a four-wheeler
you know there's there's a there's a
whole bunch of different
[ __ ] going on over here so why please
people from the middle east
please keep writing in and telling me
about uh
tell talk to me about everyday life over
there because we don't know anything
about they don't [ __ ] tell us
anything over here
um all right love from morocco
all right hey billy crimson balls burr
look at this [ __ ] look at that this is
what i'm doing right now you know i'm
going to pat myself on the back
i am humanizing all of the world because
look at them all breaking my balls just
like you guys do here
in fact some of the best ball breaking i
ever got was when i went to india
and of course ireland and scotland but i
knew that was coming
but all right anyway hey billy crimson
balls burr
i heard how excited uh you got when the
two architects from egypt wrote in so i
thought i'd chime in but this time from
a different arab country
morocco i'm a 22 year old computer side
like
smart people from the middle east like
me although morocco that's uh
that's northern africa right is that
what that is
ah geez i used to know this [ __ ] i was
really into geography at one point in my
life
and then i started drinking morocco
map is that near like algeria or some
[ __ ]
all right here we go
algeria what the [ __ ]
you know can you just show me a image
just show me a picture of it
oh there it is right next to algeria
crushed it
oh wait a minute now does morocco have
uh you played it for her now play it for
me
isn't that where that is wherever
wherever humpty bogart was
casablanca i don't know
anyway well at least i know where you
are i know where you uh
and i stopped myself before i said
something really dumb there like hey
it's in the middle east no it isn't bill
all right
uh all right i heard about morocco i'm a
22 year old computer science student
from morocco and listening to your
podcast help me get through my
the day a lot easier i'm often laughing
my ass off listening to you rant about
stupid [ __ ] while i'm nerding out in
front of my computer
i just wanted to ask you since you've
been traveling a lot in recent years
have you ever been to morocco i haven't
if so
what did you think of it and if by a
long shot
you'd ever do a show in morocco i
wouldn't miss it for the world thanks
for all the laughs and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah i mean
i don't think that we've been [ __ ]
with you guys have we
i mean that's that's how i travel
you know i i gotta you gotta look up
like what in god's name
did we do to you guys all right um
would i do that i mean i can't do it
during covet but yeah [ __ ] yeah i've
never been to africa
never been to that continent so uh
that's something i'd like to do i really
have no desire
to go on a safari in south africa
because i feel like
we've already taken over all of their
land they have this little patch
left and now we're going to be driving
around
watching them [ __ ] eating each other
in on jeeps it's like
why don't you just [ __ ] leave them
alone
um but having said that um
you got to give it up to africans the
level of [ __ ] animals that they have
in that on that continent and they
survived
is [ __ ] unbelievable you know what i
mean like i said
i get freaked out like when i like if i
go on like a hike
you know there's places in l.a where you
can actually run into bears so i i'm not
going
you know there's like [ __ ] mountain
lions and [ __ ] like
yeah i'm not i'm gonna stay on a [ __ ]
elliptical i'm gonna walk around
a block but i saw this thing one time
about a tribe in africa and they are so
good at killing lions
that the lions see them coming and they
run away
and all they're coming out with is they
got a [ __ ]
you know it was a spear and a shield
and they walk right up to the [ __ ]
the dude lion
and it's it's just over they got like
this thing it's
it's weird they look like riot police
they come up and he got the shields in
front of him
and then some dude just [ __ ] fires a
spear
goes right into the line the lion's like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and by
and then they all just it's over it's a
quick
[ __ ] death and um and they're going
and they're on foot
walking out on foot like all right you
guys want to eat lion tonight and they
just go out and do them
it's pretty badass but anyways evan said
that
like i really like um
you know as much as i [ __ ] eat cows
and chickens and pigs i've been trying
to lay off the fish
um unless it's some man-made [ __ ]
i'll eat a man-made salmon at this point
i'll roll the dice i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean and actually in a
lot of ways it's probably more healthier
than the one than the uh
the other [ __ ] the wild salmon because
you know
what the how much we polluted the
[ __ ] oceans i don't know
i can be honest with you guys i don't
even know what i'm talking about right
now but like you know
the big game [ __ ] just just i just wish
that like
there was a way to kind of give them
some of it back you know
lessen the populations around the world
let the fish have the ocean again
i'm getting really [ __ ] hippie here
but we we really are just like
you know what did bill hicks say a long
time ago we're a virus with shoes
we really are um
i remember joe rogan had this great blog
that he wrote when he was flying over
the country he was looking at the cities
and just saying we were like a fungus
i don't think we're all bad but like we
should definitely i don't know
trying to reel it in a little bit um i
would absolutely do a show in morocco i
hope
we get to a point at some point where
you know we get a cure for this [ __ ] and
stuff opens up again why the hell not
seems like a beautiful place all right
egyptian architect
in japan all right
dear billy no liquor i know i'm coming
up on two years everybody november 24th
two years um i don't even think about it
anymore although the other night i
watched somebody oh i watched this
[ __ ] unbelievable movie that my wife
loved and i had never seen before
it was matthew broderick and reese
witherspoon
were in this movie and it was about a
teacher
that gets fixated on this student and
he's trying to
stop her from achieving its um
i absolutely loved it but anyways one of
the one of the
actors in there playing a dad was
sitting there and he had a scotch
or a bourbon and he had it in a high
ball glass and oh
it was that time of night when i used to
drink him
and i was literally uh i was laying on
the couch with my wife and my head like
like
popped up it's like oh
oh i'd love one of those but other than
that i don't really think about it but
every once in a while
you know i started thinking about that
dad that character being like
i wonder if he can just have one he just
has that one he sips on it
you know
i don't know um
thank god i got kids that's what i
always think of anytime i get tempted i
go do i really want to do this no i
don't
all right um egyptian architect uh dear
billy no liquor
i'm a 30 year old egyptian architect
working and living
in the great city of tokyo another place
i'd love to go
i heard on your previous episodes that
there is at least
two other architects listening to your
podcast and i gotta say
your podcast helps us push through hard
tasks
and tight deadlines um
that is unbelievable why my podcast
is because it's so [ __ ] stupid um
it gives your brain a break also all of
my co-workers at my company are japanese
parentheses well no [ __ ] yeah because
you're in japan except for two polish
guys who started working about a year
ago
i introduced your podcast to them after
they complained about how stressful it
is working in an environment
where everything isn't in your native
language and that they feel drained at
the end of the day
needless to say after i recommended your
podcast we would laugh our asses off
at the jokes you make on the podcast and
it seems like it's helping them
throughout the day look at these guys
polish they probably they speak
polish right they go to japan they learn
japanese and then they can speak english
incredible people out there
it seems like it's helping them
throughout the day i myself had moments
where i would cover my face so no one
could see me laughing
and the first time you did the club uh
the club
w bush ad read i had to go under my desk
as i'm f
and act like i was fixing something with
my pc just so i could laugh my ass off
wow that was a long time ago thank you
for the great podcast and god bless you
and your family all right thank you
thank you guys for listening um all
right
here's another one 911 surfer
hey william you mentioned on your third
thursday november 5th podcast that while
in new york
after september 11th you heard of
someone who rode the building down
someone did do that his name was pasquel
bizzelli
also known as the 911 surfer
and they do constantly interview him
make national geographic documentaries
and books
lots of stuff that defies logic to
happen that day
read where did the tower goes with the
skeptical mind
anyways best of luck with your future
endeavors and go [ __ ] yourself
so i'm supposed to get into conspiracy
theory about who knocked that down but
i'm supposed to believe that someone
[ __ ] surfed
a goddamn skyscraper that [ __ ]
wasn't an unplanned implosion i'm not
reading it i'm not reading it it's
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] the problem with the
[ __ ] internet is is everything is
presented as fact i'm not wasting my
time reading that
um i was in new york i was watching the
news
the whole [ __ ] time you cannot ride a
[ __ ] building down
how did he write it down
what do you do you grab a piece of
carpet
if you're in a [ __ ]
maybe if you want a ranch a one-room
ranch and the whole [ __ ] thing
pancaked
do you want to have all the the roof of
a house fall on you
why am i getting upset by this okay
buddy you know what it happened you're
right it happened
happened we never went to the moon but
this guy [ __ ] okay
all right from denmark dear billy blue
uh
thank you so much for all the great
content you put up for free i don't
think you get enough credit i get plenty
of credit
um thank you though i was wondering if
you heard about the pro
uh the protests we have here in denmark
you know what i did hear that there was
some protesting going on there
i didn't read about it somebody who i
hang out with who's smart
mentioned that there was for nine days
the streets outside
parliament were flooded with people
protesting a proposed law
that would be able to define groups as
being vaccinated
or not vaccinated
oh wow this is a gray area people who
refuse
vaccination could be coerced through
physical
detainment by the police this article is
in english and explains in more detail
short enough to read on the podcast okay
let's look at it oh my god
what is denmark's proposed epidemic law
why is it being criticized
this is not short enough to read on the
podcast
all right the new epidemic law would
replace an emergency law passed in the
spring which gave the government
extended powers to intervene in society
in order to fight the kovid 19 pandemic
um as well as enforcing quarantine
measures
the existing law empowers the
authorities
prohibit access to public institutions
supermarkets and shop
public and private nursing homes and
hospital and also to impose restrictions
on access to public transport recent
instances in which the emergency law
has been used by the government to
implement rules include the partial
lockdown of north
jutland and enhanced national
restrictions including
okay so they're basically part of this
thing is they're going to force you to
get
a a a vaccination which god knows what
it does to you
well here's the thing about that uh you
kind of
people back them into a corner by not
doing
the non-vaccinated route of just wearing
a [ __ ] mask and staying six feet
apart
people didn't do it so
i'm not saying that the government's
innocent here and what they're trying to
do
but your fellow countrymen around the
world
have now put governments in a position
to pull this off
because you won't [ __ ] do what
they're telling you to do
now evil [ __ ] can come up with some
[ __ ] let's give them uh
you know let's give them this
vaccination that stops covid and makes
some
kind of lethargic
anyways he goes i think it's important
for countries to know that they can
change with protest and that this is
something that could make its way
to their governments lawmakers in europe
we tend to not like being put on lists
because of what happened the last time
people were told
they were different sorry about my bad
english your english is great thanks for
efforts for family my whole family loves
the show even my grandfather that's
awesome
um yeah well how does protest work in
your country in our country if you
protest you get the living [ __ ] kicked
out of you
um throughout history if you protest you
were risking getting killed it's just
how we this is just a violent place over
here this place was
taken violently it's it's maintained
violently
it's just a violent we uh
it's i just think it's just violent over
here i just it blows my mind when
i go to other countries and the cops
don't have guns
uh you know and you watch a
a guy has a knife and he's acting crazy
and then they just get those plastic
partition things they just sort of
[ __ ]
bum rush the guy and they get the knife
that's every time i watch them like
that guy gets shot a hundred times over
here um
i know just different philosophies
i don't know i don't know anything all
right mexican food rant
hey bill was just listening to the
latest thursday afternoon podcast where
you talked about checking out mom and
pop mexican spot for the first time
yeah i went there i i did i talk about
that
oh the thursday one yeah i did i did
okay i'm a 25 year old mexican dude
that [ __ ] loves to cook and a
family's
slash community that taught me right so
i figured i'd chime in with
my unsolicited opinion kind of a long
one so bear with me no i love listening
to
this type of [ __ ] uh now where
[ __ ] up is trying to judge
a place off their burritos
some real gringo [ __ ] all right that was
a wrong thing
all right all right so i i shouldn't
because this is a deal when i go to a
pizza place
i just order a margarita i order
something you know with no toppings
to judge it and uh you know
i love a chicken burrito so that's what
i base it on so evidently that's some
real gringo [ __ ] i'm getting the real
talk here i love it
don't get me wrong i love a burrito as
much as the next guy but my experience
white people always reduce mexican food
to burritos
no burritos and tacos he says burritos
exclusively like there isn't an entire
goddamn menu
at these places you can't even get a
burrito in mexico they'll look at you
like you're a [ __ ] idiot
um well you know it's a whole new
[ __ ] cuisine you know
you're dipping your toe in i don't know
i get i get like
it's intimidating i don't know what all
that [ __ ] is
so i i just stay at my safe place
i go italian restaurants nine out of ten
i'm getting the chicken parm
uh mexico is one of the most amazing
food cultures in the world the amount of
crops we all take for granted that
originated there is insane avocados
cocoa corn tomatoes chili peppers
vanilla to name a few i love all of that
stuff
uh chili peppers if they're not too hot
uh now i can't speak for the
when it gets so [ __ ] hot it just
overpowers the entire thing i feel like
i'm at a party
and there's 30 other people i want to
talk to but this one
[ __ ] won't shut the [ __ ] up i feel the
same way
about um about what what is that [ __ ]
um uh what was that [ __ ] that they were
just putting in everything
um oh i know it i know it's right on the
tip of my tongue
what was that truffle oil is the same
thing just
overpowers anything that it's in um
and in japanese cuisine those that
yellow paste that egg [ __ ]
what have you put that in oh my god it's
just you know it's there
ethel showed up you know i hate stuff
like that i like stuff that sort of like
you know
gets in the mix and is a good [ __ ] you
know over by the fridge tossing your
beer right
um anyway now i can't speak for the
specific
uh place you went to but i remember
recommend you grab some tacos
al pastor i'm gonna say everything like
a white guy next time you check it out
that's a safe bet most places all right
good [ __ ]
tacos are a better choice than burritos
almost every time
actually way more flavor per square inch
i know why people think mayo is spicy
but don't be afraid to throw some extra
salsa
on there too it builds character um like
i said
i don't mind if it gets a little bit hot
but if it's gonna get like obnoxiously
hot my nose is running and [ __ ]
and i have to build a tolerance up for
it
i mean if i got to build a tolerance up
i want to be getting a buzz you know
what i mean
um some of my other favorites uh to get
at taquerias are tortas
it's a type of sandwich in
soppies soapies all right this this this
all my pronunciation here is for anybody
mexican listening so they can laugh at
me which are
fluffy fried discs oh did you fry it
what a surprise
[ __ ] lunatics you guys even fry ice
cream like it's not even fattening
enough
um of corn dough topped with the usual
stuff
all right i'm going back to this place
you know what
you've inspired me i'm going back there
and i'm gonna order this stuff i'm gonna
copy and paste
this put it on my desktop and i'm gonna
go back and i'm gonna order some of this
stuff
um anyways uh i recommend just asking
them what their signature dishes
if you're a seafood fan mexican seafood
or
mariscos is is the [ __ ] highly
recommended
looking into that whole world all right
i could go on for days but i'll leave it
there well you know what here's the deal
i'll go out and i'll try some of this
stuff over the next month and uh then
i'll check back in with you
i just want to thank you for doing this
[ __ ] thing twice a week it always
helps me with rough times a couple weeks
ago i lost my cousin of suicide oh man
that's brutal i've lost a couple friends
of that
he was my closest and oldest friend a
week after that i lost my uncle
on the same side of the family it's been
incredibly difficult but your dumb ass
show
has been a companion throughout i know
you'd be the first to say
you're a [ __ ] idiot but i appreciate
your perspective on life and hard times
uh you seem to know what's really
important uh if you ever find yourself
up in northern california
uh i'd love to buy you a beer and share
some recipes take it easy and go
[ __ ] yourself all right what a good man
i appreciate all of that
um i should have been asking more all
right japanese people
all right when i go to your restaurants
i always get a spicy yellowtail hand
roll
and uh edamame
i'm basic you know i find something i
like and i i stick with it and i try not
to stray
you know these are probably you know i
bet most of the stuff i get are like
americanized japanese sushi so that's
another reason why i got to go to tokyo
i'm just going to cheat off other people
and i'll just see what they're ordering
and i'll go and get it what i do every
once in a while is i will go
and i just you know if i'm with my wife
because she's more adventurous than i am
when it comes to that [ __ ]
and if the option is there we just have
the sushi chef
make what he or she wants to make
um i find then i'll get outside of my
comfort zone
but that's cool man that's actually you
know what that's a good new um
segment for the podcast right in from
different countries
and tell us uh how to order all right
and i'll tell you how to order you guys
ask me your questions hey i'm coming to
america where should i go
what should i get and if i can't answer
the question my other listeners can
all right dumb dumb on questions on the
job here we go
here we go here we go um
ballpark take me out to the ball game
all right first time long time big fan
all right
just want to say thanks for all you do
and for letting me feel like
uh there's at least one person out there
who feels
who who i feel is also riding that
razor's edge of always just about to
lose their [ __ ] but at least but the
last second calms down enough to just
let it go i
i try to do that i don't do it too well
wanted to share five dumb questions on
the job working at the ballpark here in
seattle
number five do we have to stay for the
whole game
that is insane hear this one a lot never
understood why this is an alcatraz
just leave whenever you want that's
exactly what you should say
uh number four why can't i buy my kid a
beer
happens a dozen time a year some dad
buys two beers and lets his under
age kid have one and then just lets
his obvious underage kid
hold it and drink it around the ballpark
when confronted they
always play the but he's my kid card
and we got to ask them to leave yeah i
mean jesus christ
you got to sneak your kid a beer at a
game but you got to do it you know
you got to make the ballpark not get in
trouble
um where's the bathroom seems like an
innocent enough question but when you
hear it 300 times a game it drives you
nuts
you're in a stadium that's pretty much a
circle just start walking in any
direction and you'll hit a bathroom
dumbass
um can i keep my fake id
for some reason here in the pacific
northwest kids get their hands on a ton
of fake ids and they always
look pretty legit but when they get
busted they always ask for their fake id
back because
they paid for that that's hilarious hey
i paid for that cocaine
um who's the home team pretty much
self-explanatory and it happens way too
much
thanks bill have a good one all right
mailman
hey beautiful bald bill uh my family and
i love your
comedy and podcast i'm a postal carrier
and i deliver in the north i'm not gonna
say where in case you get in trouble
here for eight years here are the five
dumbest questions i've got
number five are you the new guy it
really throws people off that somebody
other than their normal guy
is delivering mail it's like they don't
understand a day off
number four who is the current resident
and why do i get their mail
uh i get this all the time i have to
explain to people it doesn't matter
whose name
is on the letter barack obama mickey
mouse current residence mail is for the
address i've literally had people scream
at me
that they don't want them it's like they
never heard of a trash bin
number three i just ordered from xyz
website an hour ago when should i expect
my package
i don't know dude i don't work for that
website
number two when does the fedex office
close
i don't know dude i don't work for them
seems like you have to say that a lot
number one
when did you start delivering on
saturday as far as i know since ben
franklin was appointed the postmaster
general and it hasn't changed since
you gotta love you gotta love when you
got the great comebacks
quick bonus story one time i saw someone
put a duct tape
wrench or duct tape wrapped sorry
all right i'm just looking at my record
i think it's gonna crap out on me here
um one time i saw someone put a duct
tape
wrapped shaw's bagged with a sweater in
it
on the bag in pen it said return to
amazon
being an ass [ __ ] i wrote on a sticky
note
needs postage come back the next day
there's a single stamp on the same bag
like a grandmother sending birth a
birthday card
thanks bill you're the all right awesome
all right um
i think this thing's gonna crap out i'm
not gonna read the last one i'll save it
for thursday
all right that is the podcast everybody
thank you so much for listening and the
people around the world uh
writing in has been awesome thank you
for the food advice and all that [ __ ]
let's go you guys have a wonderful
couple of days
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on
you on thursday